[Musique]
voici l'équipe b ici l'équipe italienne
est là les russes de jeunes rugbymen de
sept pays européens se sont affrontées
le week end dernier sur la pelouse
d'elancourt et dans ce genre de tournois
gagnés à peu d'importance c'est la
rencontre des cultures qui compte c'est
différent parce qu'il ya des hommes
nouveaux clubs
tu connais pas leur style de jeu et a
aussi des nouvelles règles donc c'est
très intéressant et on découvre un tas
de choses qu'on ne connaît pas là bas en
belgique et c'est super chouette
et attention ne pas confondre les règles
d'un pays à un autre dans les mêlées en
belgique on peut pas bouger
on peut pas contester la balle qui en
est qu'en france on pousse on compte s
la balle ça change pour les entraîneurs
le voyage prend aussi la forme d'un défi
normands n'ont joue en italie mais avant
très bien organisé et les niveaux de
niveau sportif les niveaux de
compétition seront très haut pour les
organisateurs cette édition qui a réuni
sept pays européens est une réussite
les années précédentes le club n'avait
pas attiré autant d'équipés étrangères
on organise un tour l'international adif
en attendant juste français qui convie
régulièrement avec son sympa pour faire
vivre des choses différentes aux jeunes
en fait c'est vraiment ça l'idée c'est
de jouer avec des adversaires qui
parlent pas la même langue que nous eh
bah c'est ça plus rien à voir c'est
l'équipe d'oxford qui a remporté le
tournoi mais tous les jeunes apprentis
rugbymen sont repartis vers leur pays
l'esprit plein de beaux souvenirs